for gemma roberts the four walls of her
front room are all she can know for the
moment you're gonna do the ankle stretch
unable to move far and breathless after
spending two months unconscious on a
ventilator
she is totally reliant on her fiance
eight
whilst i was in the coma i did have
eight cardiac arrests
suffered with sepsis i had to have
dialysis
and my family were contacted
quite a few times
and say i probably wasn't going to make
it i can't thank everyone enough that
saved me
gemma decided not to get the vaccine but
now wants to warn others of the dangers
you don't want to be 35 and having
somebody else to cook your food for you
help you walk again
and
basically learning everything from when
you were a baby
but gemma is not alone
kovit's devastating legacy has led the
warrington and holton hospital trust
where she was treated to set up a
dedicated unit for people suffering with
the long-term effects
the people who are coming to us tend to
be
um middle-aged younger
people who had good jobs
uh they've got family responsibilities
they might have carey responsibilities
and suddenly they're shattered and they
can't get out of bed in the mornings
properly and their lives are completely
turned upside down
and as we move into winter there is
nervousness across all the services here
with patients waiting longer for planned
surgeries the next few months will be
difficult at this hospital the operating
theaters are now running at nearly full
capacity but it's clear that covid is
still having a massive impact on the nhs
now here they are trying to get through
the backlog of surgery but with the
emergence of a new variant
there is still no end in sight to the
disruption to waiting times
okay if you just relax your arms it's
just gonna go a little bit tight thank
you lewis [ __ ] was meant to have his
knee surgery before the pandemic
he has now been treated but it's been a
rough couple of years
you get very stressed versus anxiety
obviously but it just because
it plays
um
how long is a piece of string when are
they going to do it especially with the
curved restrictions etc
and the spectre of covid is everywhere
extra cleaning takes up valuable
resource
and with nurses changing ppe around 50
times a day it all adds up to time that
could be spent with patients
coronavirus is still challenging every
aspect of what the nhs does new variants
coming out and
we don't know what impact that's going
to have on the system and uh how much uh
pressure it's gonna it's gonna create
again you know and every time we have
one of these you know situations
it
just basically prolongs the waiting
again you know it uh eats up into some
of the games we've made
since the pandemic started there have
been so many unpleasant surprises
and the new variant leaves us all with
so many unanswered questions
gemma is hoping that she will get well
again soon and make a full recovery
but in a time of covid she knows there
are no guarantees
thank you
alex rossi sky news
warrington